hey I'm Josh Wolf and I'm Jacob wolf and
this is family tussle the father-son
competition show where the loser has to
do an embarrassing punishment let's go
competition today is a slam dunk contest
for a long time I held eight foot dunk
contest in my driveway with a lot of my
friends so I've been doing this for at
least a decade the first time he dunked
actually on a 10-foot hoop he dunked
over me so his junk was right here I was
like oh you're never doing that again
he's
half Jewish half asian I don't know how
he grew over six feet that just like two
negatives made a positive
I got some dudes he's coming
he's gonna try and get a bunch of style
points over actual execution points
explosiveness that's that's what for me
is my strategy boy
we've all seen these ducks get your
technically good athletic boring ass
dunks ready for some entertainment
today joining us my buddies James and
Norm they're gonna judge this slam dunk
competition I think age before Beauty
you first
I call this one the uh the uh windmill
yes that's what I got
[Music]
oh I think I snapped it just so you know
from my first dunk I'm gonna jump over a
car okay okay
[Music]
nice okay nice vintage Corvette don't
land on it Norm great note
all this dunk
the auto trader okay
[Music]
I liked it I liked I liked the leg
spread yeah yeah you know Jordan is of
it all I did I did
this next one uh is timeless I'm gonna
call it the goat
butter oh okay
better oh okay
ponytail flowing it's like it's like if
Steven Seagal was dunking you know
so this dunk is called the ballerina
[Music]
commitment man you know first of all
pull up your time
he completely ripped in pale 50 year old
man
strong ass vampire
if the whole thing is for you to be
blindfolded don't be honest that looks
like a cloth that's a little
[Music]
you can't see okay
[Music]
okay
I like the extension there did that go
in
I did that oh did that go away okay okay
I don't know dude your dad's really he
really thought this oh wow I thought he
was gonna get himself out
oh [ __ ] wow
all right
[Music]
this chunk is called the [ __ ] this is
how I ball
you have left me speechless bro
[Music]
blood but this what I don't even know
what I just saw the front out chaps
that's I've never seen those
yeah you pitched me white Father and Son
dunking I don't know if I necessarily
like rush to see that yeah Josh's last
dunk
is not going to get a great score from
me because I I didn't I didn't want to
look at it he was bold he took chances
he did he did and I don't know how much
we're gonna weigh that but if we weigh
that a lot that could take him over the
edge bring the boys I'll bring the
fellas out man bring the fellas time for
some real talk you look like bad guys
from the Ninja Turtles the live show
Josh looks like a rocker who just got
out of rehab you know like yeah like his
his skin is clear now and he's wearing
the Jordans that his black roommate gave
him yeah yeah
if you can stay off the [ __ ] yeah stay
off the ship that keeps you real use
your own Jordan Ones yeah and then okay
round three I felt lied to and deceived
I I felt like you could see we could
disagree with that yeah
and I would love to see you in an
argument with your girlfriend oh I
definitely do yeah
the last one was again the Houdini the
[ __ ] yes he called it it was real like
if like The Purge was a porno this is a
progression jump as high as I can spread
my feet do a George impression right
we're impressed second one using my
remaining athleticism for like footwork
yeah you know like crazy footwork and
spinning prior to dunk yeah last dunk
was Will me out there yeah wheel me out
he didn't even walk out [ __ ] cart me
out we owe me out there yeah I'm gonna
give it what I got yeah
I will give her what I got out of all
your dunks I watched that one the least
because I just have a gist of wishes
because he had three balls with him at
that point
[Music]
because it wasn't about just once your
feet leave the ground I'm gonna throw
James smooth under the [ __ ] bust and
call it a tie and just go eight and
eight okay so Jake
it's a dunk contest you know and that's
what
I had to keep reminding myself and I'm
giving you a nine yeah okay all right
well I feel like a 10 is right around
the corner now
Josh I it's like this is not the NBA
yeah this is entertainment that's right
this is YouTube this isn't the bubble
this clicks clicks baby clickbait I'll
be honest maybe only 30 of the people
watching this video even watch the
current NBA what's the last dunk besides
these that 60 of your audience may have
seen in the last five years I mean we
added 16 30 which is 90 but that's close
oh yeah yeah but the fact that you
called me out of my mouth that's not
good for you I don't like her I think I
think I think he felt the loss brewing
and he just wanted to lean into it I
don't want to even make this any longer
I'm that petty I thought the outfits
were great the performance was amazing
don't you make me look stupid
don't you do that to me don't do that
we want to thank the judges guys thank
you so much that was super funny I'm
always impressed with how springy you
are dude but that was really good I was
impressed that you could actually still
get up to eight feet I'm also amazed you
were able to get out of that little box
and not just get stuck there me too yeah
um all right listen dude I love you love
you too that was awesome thanks I
appreciate it okay Jacob
what's my punishment
what are we doing here what well you
know you said you said I looked like a
dolphin with my shirt off yeah
that you're gonna be the one that looks
like a dolphin
let's go meet your technician how are
you okay pleasure good to meet you there
is there gonna be any blood situation
I hope not but that's not the answer
we're gonna figure it out yeah okay
that already doesn't feel good now I'm
really making sure that I'm getting it
in there yep
oh
that was not fast
you want to see can I tell you something
that's a lot of hair sir yeah
Jesus Christ
this part feels like it's been some time
coming
that's an awful picture for an older
brother to take of his younger brother
see you at home
yeah you nailed it
everything hey
[Music]